Ma'Am.
It's just,
it's still good.
Yeah.
You don't even understand what he was saying.
Sometimes you're like,
I can't do that.
A lot of you do that.
How do you do that?
I can't do that.
And he's doing it sober.
He's not like some dudes who do that.
They're all Adderall our up.
No,
he's on the Nache.
I liked these kids in school.
I'd just be like,
you know,
I was just the kid that was just like kind of like more chill.
I don't need to like,
and sometimes when you just goes over stupid stuff,
but I do wonder if he's learning anymore.
That's the one thing.
Yeah.
Cause he doesn't like to have like,
it's like once he has an opinion,
like I like to be like to have conversations and I like to be wrong about the
conversation cause I don't know everything.
I think that's kind of like why people love this podcast so much.
Because you're open to learning anything.
Like it would have people on this podcast,
you're like,
what was he having?
You know?
Because there's some,
there's always something that you can learn.
There's always something that you don't understand that you don't know if you
have an open mind.
Right.
And I think that in many ways,
and that like sometimes he's just not open to learning about certain things and
then somebody might know something about a culture beyond what he knows.
And it's just like,
nope.
That like the idea,
right?
Like it's just drives me crazy,
but I like him is really fucking smart.
That's the problem.
Exactly.
But he thinks everyone is stupid.
Yeah.
Like,
no,
like I hated,
like I got so annoyed with like the Kanye West,
like four seconds.
He like writes an article saying Kanye West is just crazy.
And I'm like,
yeah.
And I wrote him an email.
I was just like,
dude,
like I understand that to you and the way that you've done your life,
this doesn't make sense.
Right.
But this is actually really important for black people to see this.
It was the most important thing.
Him,
uh,
like,
you know,
him tweeting out.
I love the way and things,
but beyond that saying that he openly supported the president.
So I can see why Ben shuts or something like that down initially because to him,
like culture is not the way you talk about politics,
right?
Like because he's by the book.
But he has to understand that by the book is not the way people in the hood or
being raised by the book.
It's not the way people in the projects are being raised.
He people have had their families destroyed and decimated by,
by the welfare system,
right?
The fathers aren't even at the homes.
You know,
the single motherhood rate jumped from 25% in 1965 to 74% today.
And so these kids turn to culture to father them.
They turned to Jay z and Beyonce and hip hop and Kanye and to tell them what's
right and what's wrong.
So for so long,
because the left had a stranglehold on culture,
they've had a stranglehold on black America.
So the most significant thing that opened up this dialogue beyond the work that
I was doing was this simple tweet.
And the simple show of support from Kanye West.
And I was so frustrated that he had,
he had to like in that moment just write like dismiss him as crazy.
It's just like,
dude,
like just be willing to learn.
Like,
you know,
just be willing to say like,
I don't understand why the hell this is the way that this is black people
willing to talk about politics.
Right?
But maybe there's something here.
And I always understood that culture was the most important vertical.
When Charlie and I first met and we sat down,
I defined three verticals.
Charlie Kirk,
Charlie,
Kirk.
Okay.
So Charlie Kirk is like this 18 year old.
Like we started turning point USA who I work for when he was 18 and he is like a
savant.
They call him like Trump's boy wonder.
Like he's a brilliant,
if you want to talk about like smart beyond like get the smartest person I know
is Charlie Kirk hands down and he's only 24.
Um,
he didn't,
he didn't go to college just like,
I dunno,
just like it was reading weird stuff when he was seven,
you know,
I don't know,
like,
just like things that everyone's like,
oh yeah,
I just read that Thomas Soul.
He's like,
yes,
they write it when I was six,
you know,
what am I trying?
Could you not say that?
Could you be cool?
But so,
um,
when,
when Charlie and I met and I like I told him like my plan to sort of help black
America and to wake them up,
cause I understood how we had fallen victim to this brainwash.
There was the leftist dogma.
There's this idea that because we're black,
we have to vote Democrat anyway.
That is not a Democrat is racist and against helping us.
That is like what so many black Americans believe.
I believed it.
You know what I mean?
So,
and I'm a,
I'm a pretty smart girl.
You know,
I've always been a very smart girl.
I've always,
I've always been,
you know,
I've excelled in,
in academics,
right?
So how did I fall victim to it?
The exact same system,
right?
These three verticals,
the first being the family,
that breakdown of the family.
The second one,
um,
being culture,
which then to me,
like growing up,
it was like Jay z,
like Jay z was God to me.
Like I would throw on,
like,
I was,
you know,
I went through a lot of stuff when I was a kid.
I didn't have a great family,
um,
you know,
but I would throw on a Jay z album and like whatever he said,
it was like,
it was like going to church,
you know?
Um,
and then,
and I can't stand him now,
but the third vertical,
no,
because he knows exactly what he's doing and he's a trader,
but third vertical being education,
which was,
yeah,
it's like,
like Beyonce hazy under because he knows what's happening to black America.
And he's somebody that built his entire career off the backs of black America,
you know,
of being the guy who started in the honing in,
in,
um,
you know,
queens and worked at,
it was a drug dealing,
worked his way up and it became the io for Sony people in Black America.
And then he stands on stage and endorses Hillary Clinton.
He stands on stage and tells black America to put the same people in,
in the White House that locked up more black men than any present history of
United States.
Bill Clinton.
Right.
The person that stands on the crime bill of 94 is Bill Clinton.
But because Jay Z is now focused on getting a piece of the pie,
the globalist piece of the Pie,
he doesn't care about black America.
Um,
that's,
that's my opinion.
Um,
so what,
that's what it was,
or do you think that maybe he thought the Donald Trump represented a lot of
racist white people?
No.
Oh God,
no.
Not even.
Kind of,
not,
not for a single second,
Jay,
because Jay z's very smart.
No,
I didn't speak to him.
I just,
I know like I should,
it's a,
there's a,
there's a certain thing where like,
I just,
I know that Jay z and Beyonce betrayed the black community.
Like there they are.
They did it purposely for financial gain.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I think that they,
they've,
they were interested in having,
they want to be the people that control the world and they felt that Hillary
Clinton,
like,
you know,
they were working with Obama very closely,
um,
and very cluey.
Now we know that the Obama administration worked very hard to get Hillary
Clinton to office and they wanted to stay in that group.
Um,
and so they supported Hillary Clinton who was selected behind closed doors,
forget the American people to be the next president.
United.
Yeah.
So it's like two,
certainly by the DNC.
Yeah.
All 100% but beyond that,
it was an embed with Obama.
You know,
she was our secretary of state and she,
she was doing deals behind closed doors and Jay Z and Beyonce,
we're a part of that click,
right?
So they were a part of the celebrated celebrities that were allowed to go to the
White House and they'd wear the ties and everybody would be taking photo ops.
But it was a cool thing to be friends with Obama,
right?
Like nobody wants to go to the White House and like celebrities,
it's hard to get celebrities to go with Trump.
There's so much controversy attached to it.
The damage of career,
part of left and right.
Part of what's happening with Roseanne is not just that she made a racist tweet.
She was,
no,
she didn't know it was racist.
She supports Trump and then she,
her character supports Trump and people were looking for something to hate her
over and she handed it to them.
You know?